digamos que yo soy un economista y me
pregunto si en general las cosas están
subiendo de precio si eso es una
realidad y si así lo es por cuánto están
subiendo de precio ahora la manera en la
que yo resolvería mi duda es pensando en
cuáles son los bienes y servicios que
una persona normal está comprando
estoy pensando una canasta de bienes y
servicios canasta de bienes y servicios
y lo que voy a hacer es intentar pensar
esa canasta basándome en la manera en la
que las personas gastan su dinero
entonces quizás el 40 por ciento de su
dinero es gastado en viviendas un 10% en
transportación digamos otro 10% quizás
lo gastan en comida y luego yo iría al
mercado y haría una investigación del
costo en promedio de esas cosas hago un
muestreo de un montón de productos y
servicios para así yo obtener un
promedio decente adecuado ahora esta
cosa pues no es fácil de hacer pero yo
soy un economista y me interesa este
asunto así que trabajo en esto y bueno
digamos que cuando yo tomo ese promedio
del costo de todas esas cosas yo obtengo
un número
eso me da información
no te estoy dando detalles de cómo
realmente esto es calculado pero te
estoy dando una idea de cómo lo hacen y
bueno así que yo obtengo un número tú
sabes para rentar para comprar un carro
a rentar una casa las compras promedio
de comida gastos en familia y bueno
obtengo yo un número digamos que gasto
20 mil pesos en bienes y servicios esos
20 mil están basados únicamente en la
manera que yo pese la canasta ahora
supongamos que todo esto está pensado en
en el año 1 en un año el año 1 y tengo
la curiosidad si entre el año 1 y el año
supongamos que el año 5 así entre estos
años las cosas realmente subieron de
precio ahora estoy pensando en la misma
canasta de bienes y servicios así que
aquí pongo canasta de bienes y servicios
y voy a intentar averiguar cuál es su
costo promedio ponderado en el año 5 de
esta canasta esto es bastante más
difícil de lo que puedes pensar porque
te preguntarás bueno por ejemplo te
responderé porque las canastas de bienes
y servicios cambian las computadoras se
vuelven más rápidas
en esos años usas la misma computadora o
comprar la computadora promedio que
ahora sería la mejor computadora las
televisiones también sus tamaños cambian
usas de misma tv del año 1 al año 5 o te
ajustas a una tv promedio que ahora es
más grande también por ejemplo en casas
a cambiasso te quedas en la misma casa
hay muchas áreas aquí en las que puedes
cambiar de 1 a 5 años son muchos años y
esos son productos de debate en ver cuál
es realmente el costo y cuánto realmente
ha incrementado su costo a supongamos
que obtienes un promedio y averiguas que
ahora 22 mil pesos es el valor de la
canasta de la misma canasta supongamos
que de tecnología y todo el resto así
que observamos para tener la misma forma
de vida que tenías en el año 1 ahora en
el año 5 debes gastar 10% más así que
aumentó por dos mil pesos entonces pongo
aquí más 10% más caro más caro el 10% y
bueno como economista la manera en la
que tú defines tú dirías bueno el ipc
índice de precios al consumidor ipc así
se abrevia está arriba por un 10 por
ciento es lo mismo que decir que va
bueno basándote tú en la manera en la
que me diste tu canasta de bienes y
servicios tú dirías que la inflación en
los precios entre estos años la
inflación en los precios ha sido de un
10% entre el año 1 y el año 5 la
inflación en los precios y en general
todo está arriba ahora por 10% está a 10
por ciento más caro tú necesitas un 10%
más en dinero para tener la misma forma
de vida que en el año 1 en general
cuando las personas se refieren a
inflación cuando te toca ver esa esa
palabra de nueve letras especialmente en
tiempos modernos se refiere a la
inflación en los precios se refieren al
incremento general de los bienes y
servicios medido en algún tipo de
canasta de bienes y servicios hay otro
tipo de inflación es la inflación
monetaria inflación monetaria esto
de hecho de hecho están relacionadas
inflación monetaria a la inflación
monetaria es por causa de puramente el
incremento en la oferta de dinero
inflación monetaria incremento en la
oferta en la oferta de dinero y en
general si la oferta de dinero supera a
la capacidad productiva del país puede
seguramente llevar al país a tener
inflación en los precios esto lleva a la
inflación en los precios cuando se habla
de inflación de un año al siguiente se
refieren a la inflación de los precios
en la canasta algo más que verás en
ocasiones quizás en el año 5 alguien te
diga hey hola yo te puedo vender esta
linda casa como ves en el año 5 yo te
puedo vender esta casa la cual tiene un
costo digamos que en el año 5 esta casa
tiene un costo de 660 mil pesos y
supongamos y quizás alguna persona
preguntara a bueno cuál será ese costo
si lo ajustamos a la inflación que se
dio en el año 1
genial pregunta interesante pregunta muy
bien buenísima pregunta pues vamos a ver
lo que estamos pensando es si ajustamos
por el valor que se ha perdido en tu
dinero esto esto lo digo porque si las
cosas están subiendo de precio significa
que cada peso tiene ahora menor valor
puedes comprar menos con cada peso así
que pensar cuánto es ese esto ajustado a
la inflación del año 1 estás
esencialmente diciendo qué cantidad de
dinero costaba esa casa tal y cuando yo
incremente ese 10% o sea incremente por
el 10% que es lo mismo que multiplicar
por ciento 10% que que es lo mismo que
1.1 cuánto tendría que costar esa casa
en el año 1 tal que cuando yo
multiplique por 1.1 obtenga los 660 mil
pesos y aquí viene lo divertido hagamos
un poco de matemáticas para resolver
este asunto así digamos que no sé qué p
que representa el precio de la casa en
el año 1 peso 1 pero 1 x 1.1 será igual
a 660 mil pesos 660 mil pesos
cuando se toma en cuenta el porcentaje
de inflación a lo largo de estos años
esto es simple álgebra tu puedes dividir
ambos lados por el 1.1 así que vamos a
hacerlo 1.1 sobre 1.1 y estos de aquí
son inversos multiplicativos se cancelan
adiós entonces nos queda que peso 1 es
igual a 660.000 entre 1.1 primeramente
dividimos entre 1.1 por ambos lados
entonces nos queda que peso uno es igual
a seiscientos mil pesotes y bueno puedes
usar la calculadora si quieres estos
cálculos de aquí nos dicen que la casa
en el año 1 tiene un valor de 600 mil
pesos entonces en el año 1 creo que la
idea general a entiende es una casa en
el año 1 cuesta 600 mil pesos y si tomas
en cuenta la devaluación de la moneda o
lo que es lo mismo que tan más caro se
hizo todo en cinco años la casa ahora
tiene un costo de 660 mil pesos entonces
quizás escucharás a alguien decir cuando
están hablando sobre inflación o de
incremento en los precios está
casa en el año 5 tiene un costo de 660
mil pesos que ahora es equivalente a 600
mil pesos en el año 1 en dinero del año
1 y un ejemplo de esto yo vivo en una en
un lugar donde las cosas están bastante
caras tengo vecinos muy lindos por
cierto que llegaron ahí en los años 50 y
me dicen que obtuvieron su casa en 10
mil pesos y ahora las venden mucho más
caras cuestan mucho más dinero y es
verdad pero también 10 mil pesos en los
años 50 en aquellos tiempos lejanos era
mucho mucho dinero era mucho dinero y
doctores e ingenieros quizás era su
salario máximo al año no sé en realidad
cuánto ganaban ellos pero pero en la
realidad la realidad es que debes
ajustar dinero ajustarlo al año en el
que estás hablando
debes ajustarlo por la inflación con
este número del 10% ojalá sea el caso
que los ingresos de las personas
incrementen en igual manera en la misma
magnitud relativa así la misma persona
por ejemplo tú a tú con tus habilidades
tu mismo trabajo puedes puedes
permitirte comprar la misma casa que
compraste en el año 1 por 600 mil ahora
la puedes comprar por 660 mil pesos y no
será mucho la diferencia en sus gastos
sería la misma cantidad relativa al año